our story starts in 1896 in Sweden with
this guy svante arrhenius chemist
Aranea is the first person to figure out
that putting co2 into the atmosphere
could make the earth warmer but the
prevailing wisdom of the time says that
there is an infallible balance of nature
which no human actions could ever
possibly disturb so nobody takes our
aeneas very seriously until 1938 when an
engineer named guy Stewart Callendar
decides to look at global temperatures
reported over the past 50 years or so
and figures out hey what do you know the
earth is getting warmer war breaks out
in 1939 ends in 1945 and as the world's
economy recovers industrial production
goes into overdrive burning of coal and
oil puts so much sulfur pollution into
the atmosphere that it partially blocks
the sun's rays and the world actually
gets slightly cooler over the next three
decades in 1950s scientists are looking
more closely at the possible effects of
co2 emissions on global temperatures the
first time we start to realize that we
could have a major problem on our hands
a few degrees rise in the earth's
temperature would melt the polar ice cap
but the Cold War is in full swing and we
have more immediate existential threats
to think about like nuclear holocaust in
the 1960s the cooling trend continues
and there's even some fringe speculation
that we could be heading for a new ice
age that all changes in the mid 70s when
temperatures start going up again the
phrase global warming makes its first
appearance in a 1975 research paper
temperatures keep rising throughout the
80s and 1988 is the hottest year ever
recorded to that point
this gets people's attention and global
warming starts to enter mainstream
public awareness for the first time
human activities are changing the
atmosphere we face a global
environmental crisis of climate change
yes that's market Thatcher one of the
first world leaders to speak out about
climate change interesting right anyway
in 1995 an international group of
scientists issues the first public
statement that there is a discernible
human influence on global climate in
2001 they predict the 21st century
warming will leave the 20th century in
the dust over the next decade some of
the anticipated effects of global
warming start happening things like
rising oceans intense droughts and heat
waves and powerful storms 15 hottest
years in history have all occurred since
1998 and 2015 is on track to be the
hottest year ever recorded so what does
the future hold if we curb co2 emissions
temperatures could rise as little as 2.5
degrees Fahrenheit by 2099 that would be
manageable if we don't temperatures
could rise more than eight degrees which
would mean massive food shortages
widespread extinctions and a redrawing
of the world's coastlines
the story of global warming will end
with a changed climate that's inevitable
at this point how much it will change
remains to be seen